salir al zoo poder cortarse el pelo en
una peluquería
volver a nadar en una piscina o
simplemente ir a tomar una cerveza en la
terraza de un bar son las nuevas
libertades de las que pueden disfrutar
los ingleses a partir de este 12 de
abril el primer día de la relajación de
la cuarentena
después de 14 meses de solo ir a
funerales es un gran plus muy
emocionante
los comercios no esenciales de
inglaterra reino unido volvieron a abrir
sus puertas tras un confinamiento de
casi tres meses una desescalada
permitida por una ratio de contagios
inferior al 1 por ciento
pero mientras inglaterra se relaja a sus
vecinos europeos se preocupan alemania
lleva días con nuevas restricciones en
marcha en el uso de las ucis en nuestros
hospitales vuelve a aumentar y tenemos
que decir que está tercera ola podría
ser la peor para nosotros
francia también ve como aumenta la
ocupación de sus unidades de cuidados
intensivos con casi seis mil pacientes
ingresados en todo el país y aunque la
cifra es menor en españa' poco más de
2100 pacientes el país todavía siente
los efectos de la semana santa en la
presión sobre los hospitales los
gobiernos europeos siguen confiando en
la vacunación precisamente este lunes
empezó la distribución de las primeras
dosis del fármaco de johnson y johnson
para los países de la unión europea una
vacuna que podría acelerar las campañas
de inmunización al solo requerir una
dosis